واسمحوا لي أن أشارككم قصة شخصية
لمستكم بناء على
قصة ريادة الأعمال ، لذا
كنت محظوظًا منذ حوالي 12 عامًا لأنني تلقيت
دعم مؤسسة الأمير حامد سلمان مسك لرواد الأعمال
ونتيجة لذلك كنت جزءًا من
مجموعة من رواد الأعمال
أطلقنا أول حل للتكنولوجيا الصحية والتطبيب عن بعد
للعالم والذي يعمل اليوم على
تشغيل أكثر من 50 مليون
استشارة افتراضية داخل المنطقة لإنقاذ
الآلاف من الأرواح وما أحبه هو
أن وزير الصحة
وأبطال الرعاية الصحية لدينا  لقد
نقلوه إلى المستوى التالي حيث
أطلقوا المستشفى الافتراضي السعودي
ونقلوه إلى المستوى التالي ،
وسأعطيك مثالاً واحدًا على مدى تأثيرهم
على المنطقة ، أحد
الأشياء المهمة داخل
أخصائي الرعاية الصحية يسمى  من الباب إلى الإبرة
لمرضى السكتة الدماغية تحتاج إلى إجراء العملية
وتجهيز الغرفة ما بين 25 دقيقة
إلى 60 دقيقة لتتمكن من
منعك جزئيًا وكاملًا  لا يعرفون أي
شلل وكانوا قادرين على تقديم هذه
القدرة للمنطقة مرة أخرى ،
هذه أمثلة حية على كيف أن
المملكة هي قوة للتكامل العالمي